Edward Snowden von Somavia für bestimmte
Video-Chat-Animart Dringender Krieg in
Moskau Gute Nanta Snowden Guten Abend
Danke, dass du mich
als Snowden aufgenommen hast Disgaea [ __ ] Matthan ist
unter ihren 10 Tagen
Spiele gegen normale
Geister Einige Hobbingen III arbeiteten tatsächlich
von zu Hause aus als Präsident
der Pressefreiheitsstiftung in den
Vereinigten Staaten, und außerdem bin ich ein bezahlter
Dozent, den ich in letzter Zeit auf Universitäten und
Unternehmensveranstaltungen auf der ganzen Welt spreche
Meine Tage, ähm, waren
leider ungefähr vier Stunden am Tag mit
Telefongesprächen mit den Medien, aber ich denke, es ist
wirklich nützlich, dass wir 2019 wieder über diese Gespräche sprechen können.
Ich
gebe oft einen Willensanfang
Ich nehme definitiv kein Geld
vom russischen Staat Ich würde kein Geld
vom russischen Staat nehmen und sein  klar
Ich hatte im letzten Jahr großes Glück
mit der Menge an Unterstützung, die ich
weltweit bekommen habe, und der Nachfrage nach mir
, mit Leuten über diese Dinge zu sprechen, also
brauche ich es auch nicht. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich
klarer sein kann  als das, aber ich bin
völlig unabhängig. Ich lebe nicht in einer vom Staat
bereitgestellten Unterkunft. Ich habe keine Wachen. Ich
gehe herum. Ich fahre mit der U-Bahn. Ich fahre mit dem
Bus. Ich gehe in Parks wie alle anderen
wenn einfach für HT Freiheit, wenn
König Abhava hupen auf Jets
Auskultation es in einer Schräge so strömte
findit das Harmonium Bhupesh sogar
Besucher Casamance Mcgeehan auf Arzt
aufmerksam, so dass Muhammad Stiefel treffen soll
Aetna und Veruntreuer für Frauen sehen Sie mich
Reihen für das Abhava-Haus, um Asin zu erreichen
auf zwei atomare ehre gut,
man kann
die russen in russland nicht
so offensichtlich verstecken, dass das nicht meine
hauptsorge sein kann, wenn sie mich
von einem gebäude stoßen wollen, könnten sie
mich aber auch einfach wieder ins leben im
gefängnis schicken  das  Vereinigten Staaten, wenn sie
sich für Menschen entscheiden, die
mir aktiv Schaden zufügen wollen, sind eher die
Regierungen, die ich als Gesetzesbruch entlarvt habe,
nachdem ich gesagt habe, dass wir es
dabei
belassen  er könnte es leider, und
solange europa eine politik verfolgt
, die whistleblower nicht gegen die vereinigten staaten verteidigt
, sondern sie nur
vor saudi-arabien oder china oder russland schützt, werden
wir immer dieses problem haben, und
ich denke, das ist eines der traurigsten
Lehren aus dieser Geschichte, was sagt
es dem nächsten Whistleblower und was
sagt es der Welt, was sagt es
über uns selbst, wenn der einzige Ort, an dem
amerikanische Diss wieder gehört werden kann, von
Orten ist, an denen wir keine Votans erwarten würden, ist
unser Van  Deutschland 20 Buddhistische Mönche
sind gut, okay, beruhige dich, gedanke, über
gib mir rein, also müssen es unsere sein
Die Zuhörer wissen vielleicht nicht, dass ich mich nie dafür entschieden
habe, nach Russland zu kommen.
Ich war tatsächlich auf der Durchreise durch Russland auf dem
Weg nach Lateinamerika. Es ist die Regierung der Vereinigten
Staaten,
die mich in Russland gefangen hielt, indem sie meinen Pass stornierte,
und während ich auf diesem Flughafen gefangen war und mich
weigerte, mit ihm zusammenzuarbeiten
der russischen Regierung, also war ich
40 Tage lang auf diesem Flughafen gefangen. Ich habe
in 27 verschiedenen Ländern
auf der ganzen Welt Asyl beantragt, einschließlich Deutschland,
einschließlich Frankreich, einschließlich Norwegen, und
den Ländern, die wir gerne sehen
würden, die sich für den Schutz von Whistleblowern einsetzen,
also war die Antwort  und wird
immer ja sein, natürlich hat
dein Boo Snowden eine super rationierte
Person und Activa ist diese Ohana-
Vorlage, die er einen Olympus-Kashish verprügelt
hat, der als Teufelsmenschen beschrieben wurde, von denen du weißt, dass sie
einen [ __ ] Masson schlecht übersetzen, weil er
sie gehetzt und geboten hat, Hybris beladenen verdammten Stofftisch zu sehen
und Bukistan zum
Schnäppchenpreis und belieferten die Hamas-Führer auf
angenehme Weise, es ist keine Übertreibung zu
sagen, dass es so war  Es war schwieriger, über mich selbst zu schreiben
, als 2013 wirklich ein Streichholz anzuzünden und
mein Leben niederzubrennen,
aber wenn ich mich heute in der Welt
umschaue, wenn ich mir anschaue, was wir haben,
steigt der Appetit auf
Autoritarismus, eine Hinwendung zum
Totalitären  Politik in traditionellen
westlichen Demokratien stellt sich die Frage,
was wir dagegen tun können, es gibt
nicht viel, was ich heutzutage tun kann,
außer zu sprechen, außer meine Geschichte zu erzählen und
den Menschen zu sagen, warum ich denke, dass dies ein Schicksal ist
, das wir vermeiden sollten und können, aber
wir  Das geht nicht ohne das
Gespräch ji kanika Häuser, die Sie
sich ansehen müssen, in den USA sind keine Freunde,
aber mein halbes Feld ist Leutnant, den ich
oft in Versen erwähnt habe, so einfach wie das
Axiom ga'head mr.  faladi hochladen in
gaffar bringen Contin Benzie herein, das ist meine
Überlegung, sei einfach, antworte und treffe die
Botschaft, angekommen, Knotenpunkt Ohana von Maxim, Drachenansicht
, du hast ein Herz, ein Hellseher, allein, tamenund
es hat sich gelohnt, ich denke, gerade
weil wir ein Maß an Unehrlichkeit aufgedeckt haben
, das passiert  und nicht nur in meinem
Land, sondern in Ländern auf der ganzen Welt
sollen Regierungen für
ihre Bürger arbeiten,
sie sollen nicht gegen sie arbeiten, sie sollen ihnen keine
wesentlichen Tatsachen verheimlichen,
denn in einer Demokratie bezieht die Regierung
ihre Legitimität aus dem
Zustimmung der Regierung, aber wenn diese
Zustimmung nicht mitgeteilt wird, ist es nicht sinnvoll, also
ja, es gibt Leute da draußen,
die diese Behauptungen aufgestellt haben, aber wir sind im Jahr 2019, jetzt sind
wir nicht mehr im Jahr 2013, es wurden
nie Beweise dafür vorgelegt
Eine einzelne Person ist durch diese Enthüllungen zu Schaden gekommen,
und dennoch hat
sie den Pulitzer-Preis für
öffentlich-rechtlichen Journalismus gewonnen, den höchsten
Preis für Journalismus in den Vereinigten
Staaten  Die Preise auf der ganzen Welt Unsere Gesetze
wurden geändert Die Struktur des
Internets wurde geändert und unser
Verständnis der Menschen auf der ganzen Welt
wird durch den Zugang zu wesentlichen
Informationen darüber verbessert, wie
wir ausspioniert werden.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist, wenn das ein Leben
im Gefängnis verdient, dann sollten wir zumindest einen
fairen Prozess bekommen,
aber das ist das Einzige, was die Regierung
mir verweigert hat. Sie verbietet mir
das Recht, der Jury zu sagen, warum ich getan habe,
was ich getan habe, und für sie  um zu entscheiden, ob
es richtig oder falsch war
zahana court special agency kam von
gustave le hibou bhava hong kam sie
von etwa einem gig d-liebes internet grund
augen oder facebook amazon google sti
mender keine angst tod ele schüsse fangen
freizeit an sogar via via ala Daddy  Waffen
außerhalb des Filmmaterials MIT Mann, nun, die Realität
ist, dass sie beide zwei Seiten desselben
Spektrums sind,
man kann sich heute nicht um die Welt umsehen
und gehen, oh, Regierungen sind keine Bedrohung,
sie werden mit jedem Pa immer mehr zu einer Bedrohung
singjahr und doch kann
man dasselbe von diesen Internetriesen sagen,
sie haben sich die öffentliche Privatsphäre zum Feind gemacht.
Sie verdienen ihr Geld, indem sie
unser Leben als Produkt verkaufen. Ihr Ziel ist es
, jedes Privatleben dauerhaft aufzuzeichnen,
aber es ist wichtig, das zu
verstehen  Diese Internet-Giganten fungieren sehr stark
als Regierungsvertreter, und
besonders wenn Sie zum Beispiel in
Europa sind, sind viele dieser Internet-Giganten
keine Europäer, sondern Amerikaner, und sie haben das
Gefühl, dass sie keinerlei Treue
zu europäischen Gesetzen oder europäischen
Rechten haben und  warszawa abgestimmt als via Chat
ich Amit Ananda Zverkov VI Nadir Navi für
hatte nicht nicht auf dem Computer als seine enorme
Belastung Xion Xion Amphion ja, also ich tue
ich Ich verbringe fast mein ganzes Leben
vor einem Bildschirm und ich habe es
lange getan  Bevor ich meine Arbeit bei der NSA
aufgegeben habe, bin ich freiwillig eine Wohnungskatze und
wir sollten in der Lage sein, diese Entscheidungen zu treffen,
ohne uns selbst zu verletzen, und ich denke
, das ist das Problem, wenn Sie
heute gerade auf Ihr Telefon schauen  es auf dem
Tisch sitzt auf der Couch sitzt auf einem
Schreibtisch sitzt Bildschirm ist aus Sie verwenden nicht aktiv
Wissen Sie, mit wem es spricht
Wissen Sie, wie oft es mit
ihnen spricht Wissen Sie, was diese Unternehmen
über Sie wissen und die Antwort darauf
Wir alle haben uns durch
Ausnutzung des Rechts in fast allen
Ländern der Welt den Glauben geschaffen, dass
wir, wenn wir nur auf die Schaltfläche „Ich stimme zu“, klicken,
bevor wir ein Google-Konto zu einem
Facebook-Konto oder was auch immer machen,
an 600 Seiten gebunden sein können  Rechtsdokumente
, die keiner von uns gelesen hat, von denen wir wissen, dass sie keiner von uns
gelesen hat, für die keiner von uns Zeit hat, und wir
haben nicht das Fachwissen, um sie zu verstehen
, und selbst wenn wir dies getan haben, sagen diese Vereinbarungen,
dass sie jederzeit geändert werden können,
ohne uns zu gewähren  Art von Notiz,
dass es sich geändert hat, und was dies
erzeugt, ist diese Dynamik, in der Ihr Telefon
dort sitzt und einen unsichtbaren
Schaden für Sie, Ihre Familie, Ihre
Privatsphäre und allgemein für die globale Gesellschaft verursacht,
es ist wie Umweltverschmutzung, es schadet uns  Aber
es ist die Unsichtbarkeit, die es so giftig macht, dass
es so schwierig ist, darauf zu reagieren.
Wir müssen Tools entwickeln, die es den
Menschen ermöglichen, alle Verbindungen zu sehen, die
sie herstellen, um sie trivial
ändern zu können, wenn Sie jetzt einen Knopf drücken könnten
Ihr Telefon tippt einfach auf ein Symbol
und Ihr Telefon hört auf, Sie auszuspionieren,
aber wir haben diese
Gelegenheit nicht und wir haben nicht die Möglichkeit
, vernünftige Entscheidungen darüber zu treffen,
was wir tun wollen, weil diese
Unternehmen es zu einer pauschalen Entscheidung machen
Sie machen es ganz oder gar nicht, und
im Sinne des Silicon Valley versuchen sie
, es zu einer reibungslosen Entscheidung
zu machen  muss
Edward Snowden ändern in Ich singe den Fans ein
Interview und weiche den Fans aus Enoch zur Hölle
, das ist in Dornhai Playa Snowden
Vielen Dank, dass ich frei bleibe